foreign
these are big words I can't pronounce
how the hell did none of our words make
it into this oh yeah I'm looking at them
we're the New York Post
oh it looked like his arm was ashy it
was like whoa
empty MD I was genuinely about to say
the same thing
I was literally about to say the same
thing and then I was like no I have no
comment on the level of Ash on any skin
in any movie ever it's true I mean like
uh what's it called Sherry did dry him
out earlier in the film she just dried
them out so that's just realization
he is straight up the ash flakes off of
his arms our man is flaking off that's
the big reason why Sherry was able to
beat him is because he was dehydrated
always always hydrate before you fight
exactly Gatorade this is a Gatorade
commercial
welcome back to New rockstars Marvel
Studios has released its final film in
Phase 4 Black Panther wakanda forever
and undeniably Powerful film but is it
the best movie of Marvel phase 4 where
does it fall in the ranking of the seven
films of this I think we could say
slightly uneven era of Marvel well Happy
Thanksgiving everybody
we've stepped away from arguing with
your family about politics and other
[ __ ] so come join us at the nerd
table to argue with us about how Jessica
is crazy for ranking eternals is number
one I'm tired I'm saying this
what's wrong with you boss you keep
saying this we were gonna why would you
say this like this Eric what are you
doing
no right before we start recording right
after Jessica just pulled us all the
side and says let me tell you about how
perfect the Eternal is right she keeps
showing me her Druid Makari fan fiction
like enough all right
volumes one to six they were great but
thank you I'm bringing it to the brown
screen instead of the Silver Screen it's
the Browns the brows
I'm a fan of the brown scream let me
tell you nom nom nom delicious chocolate
nevermind here we go
here we go here we go here we go this is
inside Marvel new Rockstar's weekly
Marvel reaction show in this episode
there are seven theatrical films of
Marvel phase four there's black widow
shangshi the legend of the tin Rings
eternals Spider-Man no way home Doctor
Strange the Multiverse of Madness story
love and thunder and black panther
wakanda forever and the three of us will
each rank them from worst to best and
are um probably wrong opinions according
to all of you but that's the fun of this
is we're all gonna we're all gonna fight
over this it's gonna be fun and we all
love each other guys I love you guys
please be nice or don't come for me can
we make not to um not to raise our
voices at each other there's just too
much anger in the world right now
Twitter is a hellscape and let's not
turn this episode of into Marvel into
Twitter oh no I'm going to I'm going to
make sure
your promises
depends on what stupid [ __ ] you guys say
I love this I love how we're starting
off this way this is awesome I'm Eric
Boss with me today is Jessica Clemens
and Mt Jess Mt before we begin I want to
ask you how was your phase 4 compared to
the other phases is it fair to say this
is the worst phase I would not say it's
the worst phase I would say that like
considering how this is the start of a
new saga like this is just like the
phase one of a new story like the the
infinity saga's done now we're in the
Multiverse Saga so like now we're being
introduced to all these new characters
and like you know that was a big reason
why the Disney Plus shows existed I
think that this was a really fun phase
it was different it was we got a lot of
new things which is what a lot of people
were complaining about for with the MCU
for a while it's like we're getting the
same stuff like hey man we got a lot of
new stuff and if you feel like that
newness is what a lot of people thought
they wanted but they didn't really want
they wanted the same old stuff but like
the MCU was evolving so I don't know I
thought it was a great phase I thought
it was it was different it wasn't like
as hype as phase three but like it was
pretty good what do you think yeah I
think I think phase three is still my
favorite but it's hard to beat phase
three and I think it's a lot of great it
was so fun it was so fun I did love how
phase four is about mourning and
grieving completely like it's everyone
keeps dying in phase four and you know
how I love people dying so I really like
it but it's hard you can't it's hard to
compare the phases because genuinely
it's like yeah I like the beginning when
it came out but now that technology has
changed and Graphics have gotten better
and money has gotten bigger I don't like
the first phase as much as I like any of
the others does that make sense really
you know I think that's that's
interesting uh you both make very
interesting points and agree with uh
especially with what you said Mt about
it being kind of like a phase one all
over again it's like phase 1.1 and uh
you know I think the brightest spots
might have been on the Disney Plus shows
to be honest with you yeah I think 100 I
think not all the Disney Plus shows were
better but I think the best things the
best titles that came out I think
uh on Division and Loki might have been
better than all of the movies 100 in my
opinion I agree I I feel like the Disney
Plus shows allowed us to have a better
experience than a movie would because
like in a movie we're just in a movie
theater within like in two hours with
like a bunch of people but like these
shows allowed us to all bond with the
world on Twitter R.I.P I don't know
what's gonna happen with that
um but um and just like you know share
the one division mystery share like the
low-key mystery share the one division
grief and like experience that all
together so I I definitely feel like the
Disney Plus shows allowed us to
experience the the Marvel Cinematic
Universe a lot more especially also with
like getting more time to be with these
characters yeah in a more communal way I
right definitely like it felt like I uh
those shows brought me together in ways
that the movies didn't always connect me
with everyone I thought that was really
fun right but let's dive into it okay
we're gonna rank the seven MCU phase
four films we're very very nervous
especially I think there's gonna be much
more or disagreement across the three of
us compared to the the Disney Plus shows
but a reminder of the titles we're
looking at today Black Widow shangshi
eternals no way home Multiverse of
Madness love and thunder and wakanda
forever we're not including the Disney
plus titles here neither the series nor
the specials like werewolf by night or
the Guardians holiday special we're just
going to look at the seven big
theatrical releases that Marvel Studios
spent hundreds of millions of dollars on
and uh as we said when we ranked the
Marvel phase 4 Disney plus series please
know that we are coming at these movies
generally from a place of Love don't
come at us Twitter's scary right now and
we understand that your ranking is going
to be different from ours we're going to
do our best to explain why we rank it
but understand that when this is like a
snapshot of our feelings realistically I
can't speak for you know Justin Mt but
speaking just for myself my opinion my
ranking is probably going to change next
week if you were to ask me next week
because all these movies have such a
personal connection with each of us and
uh what we love about them evolves over
time you'll see it in mine completely
it's a personal connection if you were
like Jessica Basin off of MCU knowledge
and what gave you more information I
could change it I could change it
immediately and it would not look
anything like I scored it but I scored
it based off what I can watch over and
over and over again what I have watched
over and over again and what characters
really spoke to me let's start with our
number sevens who wants to go first
number seven at the very bottom
is Black Widow Jessica this is Black
Widow I wanted so much more and I will
always be mad about it my number seven
was 411 Thunder I'm very sorry okay I'm
walking away
take my damn mic and then take my damn I
agree with Jess my number seven was
Black Widow but continue Jess why why no
I want to hear him he's stupid I'm
joking I'm joking I'm joking I'm joking
I want it I need to hear this how black
widow is not your number set sorry it's
only my we have the same disagreement
about Black Widow Mt that's why
no although we knew each other no no
black I can definitely see why black
widow is at the very bottom for you
because it was wasn't like the villain
wasn't very compelling that whole movie
just felt like a lot of missed
opportunities like like you said the
other day with Taskmaster
um this opportunity there and also a
missed opportunity to tell the story of
um the the country why am I breaking out
the country that starts with a B
Budapest Budapest right um Budapest they
just glossed over the story they like
they kept alluding to this huge event
that happened in Budapest and nothing
happened so like I was so let down on
that because like I just wanted to see
that uh but Mt you weren't so
disappointed to rank it at the bottom
yeah uh so right now you're gonna make
it a case or why you should have ranked
it at the bottom I would I want to know
uh first off Jess are those your reasons
do you co-sign off of mt's reasons I
wanted to like it so much I wanted to
like it so much Black Widow is also like
a character that I don't really pay
attention to much and the the Cinematic
Universe so I was like oh she's getting
her movie give her a platform to win me
over and it did not win me over it made
me like or less and so I was like it
made me love Florence Pew it made me
love Elena and let me love uh her dad
but then even then I was like I'm not
really getting like a serious moment
even from them I'm getting just comedy
so right I just wanted a little bit more
I agree with everything both of you said
and I think realistically the biggest
missed opportunity in this movie was to
tell us more about Natasha Romanoff the
character who was killed off an in-game
we didn't get to see a funeral the whole
premise of this movie is what he said Mt
we get to finally find out what Budapest
was all about I love finding out more
about dracon's daughter I thought that
was an interesting tie-in but like we
didn't learn anything more about Natasha
Romanov in this movie uh and that's a
real missed opportunity
um we never really learned what happened
between her and Clint I feel like we
grieved more for Natasha Romanov in the
Hawkeye series than we did in the Black
Widow movie and that's really weird that
said Florence Pugh David Harbor Rachel
Weiss yeah all great actors I can't wait
to see them more in the MCU
um I think the chase scenes and Budapest
were well choreographed I love the
Americans style opening sequence but
everything with the Red Room the other
widows uh in Taskmaster just really fell
apart for me in this movie yep yeah it
wasn't really all that interesting but
like the reason why it's not my bottom
list is because of Elena and Red
Guardian uh because I do love those
characters a lot and like I'm very look
much looking forward to seeing them in
the Thunderbolts and like you know just
moving forward I just feel like that
movie should have been a Yelena movie
honestly
probably would have liked it
t love and thunder explain your choice
my biggest gripe with love and thunder
is I mean Beyond like
it wasn't really the visual presentation
as a lot of people have noted is is uh
very much different from previous Marvel
Studios films
um but like the biggest problem for me
was uh their how they treated Gore the
god butcher because in the comics where
the god butcher is a serious like huge
threat and like he butchered a lot of
gods and in Thor love and thunder we
didn't really see a lot of butchering we
didn't see any we only only saw
butchering at the beginning of the movie
really and then um he just stole a bunch
of kids and then uh you know played Gore
the babysitter for the entire film which
was a huge huge like I was very much let
down because you got Christian Bale
Christian Bale is such a great actor and
you did that's not Thor love and
Thunder's fault
like I just feel like if you're going to
Nerf Gore the god butcher then don't use
him like I just use another character
agreed like this is like a huge thing
this is like a Thanos level character
for in the Marvel Comics I feel like a
massive threat with the um with the
necro sword so I just feel like if
you're going to do a huge Villain Like
That You Gotta commit and you gotta just
go balls to the wall so like that's my
biggest gripe and like you know I'm not
I I I've said it previously on inside
Marvel that I'm not the hugest fan of um
of Natalie Portman as Jane Foster I
think she's a great actress I think that
she's a great person but I I it just I
wasn't the biggest fan of that um in
general but like I do like her or that
she got that send off and
um that she is now a Marvel Great Hero
with her own statue but anyway yeah
that's why yeah yeah okay I think that's
a fair choice I think I think Mt a lot
of people probably agree with you
um and I I applaud you for uh for
sticking to your guns there let's move
on to our number six picks I'll go first
um we'll each say what our picks are and
then we'll explain uh my number six pick
is
eternals damn I thought we'd be
different my number six is also eternals
oh okay Jess and I are on the same
wavelength so far so far so far my
number six was uh Black Widow that's
where I hopped on the Black Widow Widow
okay I was not too far away my quick uh
two cents on eternals I I just think for
me this had some of the highest highs in
phase four but also a lot of the lowest
lows a lot of the lowest lows I think
the whole story of the celestials was
thrilling beautifully designed I love
the mythology of the celestials
endlessly fascinated by the idea of like
Celestial seeds uh World forges the idea
of using uh eternals as synthetic
caretakers I just think this cast was
far too large it has too many weak links
I'm not gonna single anyone out
particular but like at least three to
four of the actors in The eternals were
not cast well in this movie uh and I
don't think they're at their best I
think the deviants are mostly
unnecessary to the story there is a
potentially great movie here like
imagine a Greek drama about ageless Gods
Beauty about how to intervene with These
Foolish Mortals and whether to overthrow
their own creators and celestials I just
think that's really hard to pull up in a
two-hour movie I think this idea would
have worked better as a mini series
um I think this story needed to leave
earth like get the hell out of that
murky ugly ship interior I thought that
setting was terrible and they spent like
the second half of that movie in that
awful ship uh and then uh maybe fight
the celestials in space maybe see other
planets or alternate Earth and the
Multiverse get destroyed I don't know I
just think there was like a more
fascinating movie in here and I think
the actors trying to pull off this Greek
drama debate yeah they were confused or
bored with that concept and like you
could see that on their faces and uh the
movie didn't deliver I agree I I
definitely agree that like
um the whole ship interior I feel like
there's a whole like a lot of missed
opportunity with the Domo ship I feel
like it's a really interesting Celestial
like how was that thing even powered
like I I would love to have seen the
inner workings of this ship rather than
being in this one room with a bunch of
[ __ ] around because Makari was reading a
bunch of books and collecting a bunch of
stuff but she didn't choose it as your
six well no because like I I really
enjoy eternals as a um for what it does
means to the MCU and like how and what
it explains about Evolution energy and
like the impact of the sun and the MCU
and like how the eternals get their
powers and like what it means for the
X-Men uh moving forward and so that is
in life we didn't get anything about the
X-Men in that movie they didn't say
mutant anywhere in the movie like they
had so many opportunities to establish
uh apocalypse with like the mutant
origin mutant DNA and they didn't they
didn't pull the trigger on any of that I
I feel like those seeds are being lame
because like if you look at eternals as
a movie it starts off on a beach and
then ends on a beach and like it's
because of like I believe it's telling
the story about Evolution and about um
you know how
eternals have been around since the
beginning there's a lot of symbolic
stuff like to long story short and like
I've been I just really enjoy that I
have the same opinion with Age of Ultron
a lot of people don't like Age of Ultron
but I really enjoy that because like of
the symbolic meaning of like Ultron and
like how he's so biblical and like what
and that God stuff that he talks about
people didn't like Age of Ultron a lot
of people a lot of people wait what
really you might okay so just me yeah a
lot of people are engaged vulture that's
like the worst Avengers
it's it's got uh definitely a mixed bag
but Jess what are your thoughts on
eternals you joke and say that I love
this movie but I did love it I did love
the comics and my and out of all of
Marvel movies I think this is one of the
movies that I really wanted to stray
along more with the comics because it
would explain a lot of stuff and the
deviance was my number one and I don't
like what they did to the deviants and I
wanted to explore the deviants more and
now that they're just basically loose
animals that just run amok they're not
really anything and I like the deviants
being able to learn and become things
without having to eat each other that
wasn't in the comics so I just I wanted
more from that but then when you said
the acting stuff it did it it's so
interesting because it's like they you
you couldn't really go down the um the a
number of casts really because they're
all very important in the comics but
it's also like you guys didn't make it
come off that way it seems like from the
movie we didn't really even need Sprite
um I I didn't like that triangle love
story I was like I don't care about this
there's bigger things happening right
now also I feel like if you're going to
have like essentially like these Justice
League like type of characters like
these super powerful characters you have
to give us like a a super epic like
super epic action sequences and we
didn't really get that with eternals
like that's one of my biggest gripes
it's like you have a Superman with
Icarus you have like a Speedster like a
flash with Makari we should be having
like
um you know your I mean your Zack Snyder
level action sequences not to you know
breakups I'm not the hugest Zack Snyder
uh guy but like he would have really
went in if he had the eternals honestly
because like he knows how to do a good
action sequence I think he would have
done a good job and fun job with
eternals I think yeah I would have been
just based off of Zack Snyder's like uh
origin of the the dark side battle on
Earth I think that made a better
eternals movie than Marvel eternals
moving now that it gets closed out I
think Chloe Chow is an amazing she's an
amazing I just think she was not the
right pick for this one yeah agreed yeah
agreed all right so MTU ranked Black
Widow number six you talked about Black
Widow earlier is there anything more you
want to add about Black Widow the whole
Taskmaster thing and obviously there's
there's room for for growth and
evolution with that character but I just
really
um was let down that like they you know
they they advertised this huge
Taskmaster matchup and like you know I
was like oh my God we have test master
in the movie and then did nothing with
it and uh the whole Drake off thing I
just don't like Drake off as a human
being so I'm just like it just really
just creeps me out so he was that good
of a character I'm just like yeah it's
just really disgusting anyway yeah
it's low when he punched Scarlett
Johansson it really irked me I remember
seeing that scene and Visually being
like um
like being mad disgusting disgusting um
shall we move on to our number five
picks yes empty what's your number five
my number five was eternals my number
five is uh Thor love and thunder my
number five is also Thor love and
Thunder
all right Jess you've been looking at my
notes again no but you know this is just
gonna make it even more painful when we
diverge real quick with Thor 11 Thunder
I agree with uh many of the things Mt
brought up specifically the character
Christian Bale I think if you bring in a
character named Gore the god butcher you
need to see him butcher more than one
God and that did not happen in this
movie and I think that was a big mistake
I think the look of this movie with all
the VFX and the volume set work which is
especially distracting the reason I rank
it higher I think than umt is I just
really still love what is left in this
movie I think Christian Bale's
performance that he gives is is
fascinating to watch
um Jess knows we saw the premiere
together I didn't tear up at the end but
it's really just because I want to be a
daddy so definitely and that's just that
speaks for Me Maybe not everyone who
watches this movie and I really just
love Thor teaming up with the Guardians
to kill those wacky Mad Max bird aliens
in act one to me that is Sublime MCU
Thor joy and I'm really I just had a
great time in the opening act of this
movie I love the idea of visiting the
eternity and how cool they made eternity
look and how eternity transforms into
love I just was that rocked I just think
like what the hell happened with this
movie like why did so much of it cut
like I need to know what happened behind
the scenes with like the notes taika was
given it seems like taika did not fight
for this movie the way he fought for
Thor Ragnarok well he only worked on a
little bit of Thor Ragnarok right it was
someone else I always forget that he
didn't write it he just directed Thor
Ragnarok that's true that's true they
had different they had Eric Pearson and
Stephanie Folsom writing the scripts of
that yeah ultimately I think this very
little this movie has stuck with me I
think the whole kid battle all the kids
of the power yeah I thought that was
really that was really that really took
me out I was like all right so this is
for the the kid audience which is like
you know I'm sure kids really
appreciated that moment and like you
know I'm not a kid so I can't really
talk for them but like it just felt
really tacked on and but it makes me
wonder who this movie is for then like
it's taking to making this movie for
kids or is he making it for adults who
want to see Chris Hemsworth's ass
because it's like it's just like he's
making his movies for like college age
and up and not for kids uh he's making
movies with irreverent kids in it that
adults can giggle at but I think that
like Trope has just gotten really I'm
really bored with that Trope of just
like kids saying bad things kids doing
it kids with the mind of taikawa Titi
inside of their kid body it's kind of
like all right like I I maybe I'm just
tired of seeing kids in movies
maybe maybe I don't want a child
an adult writing words for them it's
just weird you're right children should
write for children I realize what I'm
saying is completely crazy I just think
like there's it's hard uh I can relate
with teenage enough I can relate with
kids who are in high school it's hard
for me to relate with kids in middle
school and down just because you're not
a full person yet you're just mostly
flesh in raw emotion and you don't you
can't have a complex thought so it's
like okay you're to me it could only
serve so much of a role for anybody to
empathize with I want to be a daddy so
badly we lost all of our Middle School
viewers
they're like oh boss hates babies I put
Thor love and thunder as my five and I
think I've said this before I don't know
how I have no idea how but Thor movies
have become my favorite out of the
Captain America's Iron Man's anything
it's become Thorne what do you mean you
don't know how it's Chris Hemsworth we
know your your secrets
[Laughter]
I think it's because ultimately we're
still like especially in Voss we're
still like comedy people like we're
still comedians we did UCB improv and
sketch and stuff and I love the comedy
aspect that they bring and there's a lot
of funny things yes but I think Thor is
the essence of Comedy oh Chris Hemsworth
is so good at comedy yeah it's just
that's what he is he is the he is the
laugh he is the bit so I always love
that and it's always stuck with me and I
love it because it keeps us always
laughing and I think it's spoke to me as
like a yeah funny people can be sad at
times but I do see the quarrels and it
took me way after the premiere to notice
what the quarrels were and then I was
like no I understand yeah they did Gore
really bad
um did it go really bad the child ending
part didn't get me like everybody else
it was more so the farewell to Jane
Foster that got me and I and there's no
cancer story lines in the MCU until that
so it was like I liked it all right Mt
you have eternals at your number five
you've you've definitely talked about is
there anything more you want to add
about eternals oh no I just you know I
didn't put it as low because like of
again like the significance to what do I
believe is like what's gonna happen with
the X-men with the eternals and like you
know you know I just love this like
Chloe zhao's writing
um with eternals personally because like
it just you can tell that she really
cared about telling a really unique
story
um that was closely tied to actual like
mythology and trying to keep it
um accurate but like with a Marvel
Studio spin so like I don't know it's
it's a great movie but it's definitely
flawed and the next two turtles movie
better be more action-packed Kevin feige
please all right the end hey you know
what's interesting is the three of us
all agree that the same movies are in
the bottom three we just have slightly
different orders between me and see but
we all kind of agree that there is a
lower tier of phase four films we're now
at our number four pick we're right in
the middle of the pack and here's where
some interesting Sparks Are Gonna Fly my
number four pick is
some tea in the legend of the ten Rings
oh that's not mine mine is Multiverse of
Madness
[Laughter]
[Music]
Spider-Man no way home
let's get my explanation out of the way
because I think Jess
played them I'll go first though
um okay so shangshi legend of the tin
rings I really really did like this
movie I don't want people to get the
wrong idea I think they said the best
stunts of phase four hands down I love
the character of win-woo I love Bill
Pope cinematography all the wushia dance
fighting with win-woo and Ying Lee uh I
just think uh sunshi and Katie were
great in their own right they were just
in kind of a different movie they were
more in a completely different people
will like say oh I love the stunts in
this movie I'm like well what do you
mean specifically about the stunts and
they're like well I love how it's like
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon but it's
also like Jackie Chan and I'm like yeah
those are completely different tones I
think this movie Mostly dovetails them
right because shenshi is in like a
Jackie Chan's lipstick movie everything
with a bus with a bamboo scaffolding
that's all Jackie Chan his stunt team
but then everything with win-woo is like
a different mythological wushia style uh
natural uh style which both are
beautiful both are amazing I just think
shangshi loses a bit of that dynamism
that he had in the first act when he
gets transported to talo and with the 10
rings compound I think the final battle
with the Soul suckers the dweller in
Darkness Falls a bit flat and we never
really get an understanding of what
Shinji is fighting exactly at the moment
I think that monster is far more
interesting when it's pretending to be
other voices in people's heads I was
riveted by that I want to know why it
does that how it does that we never
really answer those questions uh and
ultimately I think what it comes down to
for me is this movie is called shanxi
and the legend of the ten rings and we
don't learn [ __ ] about the 10 Rings we
learn about their history uh the 10
Rings organization when moose history
but the Rings themselves the movie is
telling the legend of the tin rings and
in the opening 10 minutes of a Lord of
the Rings The Fellowship of the Ring we
learned everything about what the ring
of power is and the other Elven Rings
the Dwarven Rings The Man Rings the fact
that this movie does not tell us
anything about the the what the Rings
actually are and just punts that even in
the postcard itself it's like then don't
call the movie and the legend of the 10
Rings 10 out of 10 first half of shenzhi
5 out of 10 second half I can't win the
tournament in the second half I can't
wait until we get to my channel I still
really liked it I just wish we had
gotten more of different things in this
movie okay okay okay I'll take that
empty do you want to go into why you
ranked Multiverse Madness at number four
Multiverse Madness was a really great
time I really enjoyed going through the
Multiverse and um I really of course
enjoyed leading the Illuminati and like
getting the Illuminati confirmed in the
MCU and of course seeing
um Mr Jim Halpert as Reed Richards in uh
like as everybody wanted I think he I
thought he did a great job and I really
like how we they subverted Expectations
by killing the Illuminati
um off like immediately
um I just thought that you know
Multiverse Madness could have done more
with the Multiverse aspect and of course
this is a doctor strange movie like we
don't want to go two balls to the wall
with the Multiverse I like how like they
they continued that story multi of
Doctor Strange being
um a a doctor who
um is trying to be like this super
perfect person but at what cost like
he's trying to solve problems problems
but like at the cost of like a stolen by
using darkness and at the cost of a
universe so like I I really like that
but I just feel like we could have
gotten more
with the whole Multiverse aspect and
like Wanda and like I really wish that
they explained why
um Wanda went crazy with the dark hole
because like I feel like a lot of people
were upset that like oh no she's
completely different than one division
but it does make sense why she's
different from One Division because she
had the dark hold but I really wish
there was like a scene that's just like
all right everybody the dark hold messed
her up that's why that was the
significance of the final scene of One
Division like she's she's no longer okay
like her mind is not okay so that's why
she's doing all these bad things but
they didn't have that so like people
were just like why is water so different
what's going on and um yeah so I really
I feel like just for clarity's sake they
should have had something like that in
there but anyway it's number four not
not bad it's it's fine fair enough Mt
and I I think those are a lot of valid
criticisms and uh valid points in
general I have some thoughts on that
that I'll get to when when I mention my
ranking for multi-person madness but I
think Jess we all gotta know we gotta
know the thing is I I'm clearly sorry
because I now know that I'm clear I'm
sorry I I've known I'm wrong about
Spider-Man no way home you're not wrong
it's your opinion it's fine I'll okay
sometimes opinions are wrong empty it's
funny
so there's no right or wrong it's fine
if you talk to gen Z kids opinions can
be wrong
so that's why I'm saying this my that's
why I said at the beginning I said it's
based off of what I can watch over and
over again what I really liked what got
me with characters
um but if we did versus like inform
information that we need in the MCU went
on a scale them to you I would have put
no way home much higher but I think out
of my top four no way home is the only
movie where in the movie I said I'm
tired I literally
there was there is so much dialogue and
some dialogue that wasn't needed and
then I was just like okay I get this I'm
in it but then I also was like okay I'm
very happy to see Toby McGuire oh my God
I love Toby Maguire and if you're a fan
of his weird gang you even love Toby
Maguire even more because of this movie
and then I love Andrew Garfield and I
loved all these callbacks I loved it
just to get sucked away and never come
back and then on top of that the
acknowledgment of Miles hurt me the the
a black kid in Brooklyn
that's it that's all we got we're
expanding the Multiverse we're diving
into the Multiverse but they can't touch
Spider-Man and I know a lot of this
stuff is based off contracts and based
off this and that but I was like okay
out of every black person in the
Spider-Man universe I want to see Miles
Morales not all Jamie Foxx's Electro
I genuinely was like I was like okay I
get it I I cried I got emotional at it I
thought it was great but I was also like
just for just in my opinion watching it
wise I have watched it at one time and I
was fine I have not watched it again
okay
um interesting thoughts you know I'm
looking at our list right now I think uh
Mt your list might be the most aligned
with where fans are at I think in terms
of like the disappointment versus
pleasant surprise meter like I think a
lot of fans are really disappointed by
love and thunder
um but I think looking at what's left on
your list I'm like okay I think I think
most people are going to look at mt's
list and be like yeah we like empties
my list they're gonna look at just lists
and be like what the hell were they
thinking with that they're not gonna
listen to me as soon as I put their
their their God Spiderman a lot of
people did not like Eternal so like I'm
there I'd be I'm surprised if people
like I will say and I said this earlier
my three and four are interchangeable
and I'll explain why when we get to it
well um okay we're gonna get to our top
three picks in a moment uh first we want
to thank Bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode when it comes to our rankings in
the bedroom we all want to be number one
thankfully our sponsor today is here to
help Bluetooth is unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can take them anytime day
or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready for whatever an opportunity arises
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once you
approved you'll receive a prescription
within days it's all done online so no
visits the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no wait in line the
pharmacy Bluetooth tablets are made in
the USA and prepared and Ship Direct to
your door in a discrete package so if
you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
Bluetooth can help and we've got a
special deal for our fans try Bluetooth
free want to use our promo code Marvel
at checkout just paid the five dollars
in shipping that's bluetooth.com promo
code Marvel to receive your first month
free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we thank Bluetooth for sponsoring this
podcast all right we are now at our
number threes uh things have already
gotten a bit controversial but it's just
gonna get more fiery let's list our
number three picks what do you guys got
my number three is Multiverse of madness
Okay I know that there is Multiverse
Madness uh I got uh shung chi as number
three for me my number three
black panther what kind of foreign
[Laughter]
kind of forever and I go back and forth
to me it could I go back and forth with
the number two number one because both
my number two and uh and my number three
are I believe flawed movies and their
flaws are similar uh I don't want to say
what my number two is yet though um I
think that I I really give all the
credit in the world for Ryan coogler and
the team taking an impossible scenario
and somehow sticking a landing there's a
very meaningful story in here with uh
not only saying goodbye to Chadwick
Boseman but uh grieving any lost one I
think it's the prettiest face for film
to look at to listen to Angela Bassett
better win the Oscar for this movie to
know where to one of the all-time best
antagonists so why didn't I rank it
higher uh why do I think Multiverse of
Madness and no way home or above it I
think um a lot of people give their qual
they qualify their reviews with
statements like well it had to do so
much well it was really hard for Ryan
coogler I gotta stop you right there no
this movie did not have to do as much as
it did it did not have to include val
did not have to include Ross did not
have to set up Thunderbolts this movie
did not and is controversial it did not
have to set up Riri Williams I think
Dominic Thorne is incredible in this
movie but we are going to meet her in
ironheart anyway we didn't have to use
this movie to introduce her we didn't
have to have this whole Midnight Angel
subplot I don't think the midnight
Angels were as good as they could have
been in this movie I I think this movie
itself did not have to exist at all Ryan
coogler and Marvel Studios chose to go
forth to make it for the same reason
every big movie gets made because they
want to make money they want to sell
Happy Meals and I think a lot of critics
are giving this movie a free pass right
now because they believe it was mostly
respectable Chadwick Postman which it
was it did a really good job and I'm not
gonna I'm not saying that was really
easy I think it definitely deserves
bonus points for that but I don't
believe that I believe it deserves a
carte blanche and I think in a couple
months from now a lot of us are going to
start we're going to start looking at
this movie a bit more critically to a
randomless genius I I think he pulled
off a commercial hit and he gave us
something spiritually wholesome and that
was really really hard to do I think the
story of Sherry's Greek was flawless I
just think it's just that story gets
derailed by a couple the things that
have nothing to do with it thematically
I think there's a couple self-inflicted
wounds but overall for me for black
panther what kind of forever to be
number one it would have to be as good
as or better than the 2018 film and I
don't think it's as good as a 2018 film
uh and I think there are flaws with the
Multiverse of Madness and no way home I
just think uh those flaws don't pull
away from those movies as much as the
flaws of black panther were kind of
forever pull away from the story of
shuri and her grief I know I'm wrong
though that's just how I feel like there
is no right or wrong you're just
expressing your your thoughts
thank you for sharing that that was
really really great I mean I've never
been forgiving because the world's good
damn I though
I don't know if it says I'm black it hit
me somewhere but I was like God damn
okay well my number third my number
three is Multiverse Madness because and
I think my number three and number four
interchangeable Multiverse and Madness I
love completely out of Wanda um I love
Wanda I have her tattooed on my body I
love her any kind of art they can give
her great why it's not in my top two is
because I'm also tired of the trip of
making Wanda a crazy person uh I'm sorry
I I mean I get it I completely get it
here
[Laughter]
how Savannah was like pretty crazy time
it was so I love her but like my problem
and this is also yeah maybe a lot of
people don't want to fight or freaking
hear this but it's more so the fact of
like yeah Marvel does women kind of
dirty if they're not dead they're crazy
um if they're not crazy or dead they're
the Damsel in Distress being chased
around they never get like to be their
own version of a hero they don't get to
be like I'm strong and I don't need
anyone's help it's always like we have
to give them those three we have to
fridge them as they say in Chico so but
I love Sam freaking Remy and that's
where it got me because I'm a horror fan
I think they did a good job of making it
scary for kids and scary for adults I
love the way they did go into the
Multiverse uh was acting all there two
out of the four
um and I did like that they did the
Illuminati you make some good points
about it but like with mt I'm going to
address all the criticisms of Multiverse
and badass I'm gonna have to because I
ranked it in my talk too so I have to Mt
you want to explain your pick of Sean
she at number three I just thought that
like that movie was just like the most
action-packed
um and like the action choreography of
that movie was so freaking amazing and
like I just really think that Marvel
movies should step their game up like I
think she's at the bar now like
obviously like you know it's a different
type of movie like it's you know shenzi
is a very martial arts Centric character
but like man like if you're telling me
that like action sequences could be that
dope like all the time like I haven't
felt like that odd at the end actually
since the Winner's older like winter
soldier like really went ham and like I
really like you know your your fighting
Heroes like that and xiangchi really
steps it up and I'm really looking
forward to which on G sequel
um and I really like what they're doing
like telling the story about you know
shookuchi's family and like him getting
over his his own guilt and like his own
shame with his father and like when Wu
is like one of the best Marvel villains
that we've ever gotten
um and like the one I think one of the
best of phase four if not the best if
I'm trying to think
um but no oh never mind Doc Ock that
dude was too good uh but like uh Wen Wu
uh was so good and like he was such a
compelling character and I cannot wait
to see him and what if kick some butt
him versus Odin come on you kidding me I
need to see that in my system uh but yes
um great movie I agree with these and I
mean hearing the two of you explain why
you rank these other movies higher like
I I I can't argue with it it's hard
that's why I think like next week I'm
gonna be kicking myself in the butt for
ranking Chung Chi and black panther and
not higher on my list because I think
there there is really is Beautiful
Stories in those especially well kind of
forever I I think like the story the
shury's story in wakanda forever I think
is better than the central stories of my
top two and I think it's because of all
the other stuff and we'll kind of
forever that just makes me uh rank it as
number it's still in my top three I
guess
um anyway but that's me qualifying I'm
making excuses [ __ ] my number two
was Dr Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness my number one was Spider-Man no
way home how about you guys
that was my number four
it's no surprise for me that of course
the two POC films are my top two wakanda
forever is my number one and Shang Chi
is my number two if God forever never
came out xiangchi would have been my
number one my number two was wakanda
forever and my number one was Spider-Man
no way home all right yeah I put it as
my number four
I honestly I look at your list of tea
and like I think yours is going to be
the number one agreed upon list like I I
think fans this is their list like I'm
even looking at my list right now I'm
like this is just me being indulgent
with my own interests you have a very
universally uh applaudible list I think
Mt wins there's no winning it's just I
don't know I just okay I guess there's
nobody I think he has the worst list he
put Black Widow as number six
I think the rest is fine but number six
is wrong
I I have to explain why a Multiverse of
Madness is my number two okay so I'm
gonna come in by saying that Sam Raby in
my opinion could really do no wrong I
love everything Sam Ramey makes the fact
that I can find you let's say maybe make
a true same Remy film I was just
Overjoyed it's weird it's violent it's
campy it's scary I understand it's not
for everyone though
um I just think that Multiverse Madness
at the end of the day when you ask me
right now I think it is only slightly
better than wakanda forever but I agree
the central storylineable kind of river
of shuri is better than the central
storyline of Multiverse Madness but I
think there there is a good Central
storyline of Multiverse of Madness it's
a story about the dangers of
dreamwalking the dangers of focusing too
much on what might be what could be
instead of what is and that is a
sickness that infects both strange and
water and America Chavez and I love that
the I love the Dark Places this movie
goes to with those characters that we
see them dragged the worst of themselves
as they keep scratching that itch and I
I you know I think what you said about
wanted yeah I think if you watch a
post-credits scene of One Division you
have no problems with where Wanda goes
this movie I I think it's it's not as
clean as it could have been I think the
the biggest flaw with the movie is that
they should have had the villainous
wanted this movie be a Wanda from
Another Universe it shouldn't have been
the same exact Wanda from One Division I
think if they just made that Wander from
a different Universe searching for our
kids this would have been a perfect film
um maybe not perfect because I think
America Chavez is the Damsel in the
story is not that fun to watch you know
um but I think just the little the
little details in this movie carry it
for me I love the the definitions of
things like dreamwalking and incursions
the fact that numbers uh the Multiverse
universes I love the line I love you in
every Universe I think that's beautiful
I think Elizabeth Olsen completely
Savage in this movie not just in the
loud moments but in The Quiet Moments
the how understated she is I I love the
boldness of uh introducing these fan
casts Illuminati and then just
slaughtering them because yeah it's a
Multiverse we don't need a permanent
Illuminati um now as a Multiverse uh
Multiverse movie I agree with you it's
not as good as everything everywhere all
at once it's not as good as many
episodes of Rick and Morty but hey I
like that each Act explores a different
universe and explores it rather than
exploring like uh a dozen universes but
just like one scene of them I love that
we have several scenes in each of these
universes we really explore a3a we get
to see the a38 infinity war that is
insane to me seeing dead Thanos was
incredible uh I love this post-encosion
universe I think the music fight the
Danny Elfman consumers school I love
that fight super imaginative the moment
he resurrects zombies strange and then
the music kicks in and zombie straight
take over like I lost my mind I think it
has the best economy of story maybe
second to no way home
um but yeah I I think when it comes if
we're comparing damsels who get
scapegoated I think Riri Williams is a
far more interesting hero and and will
kind of forever I completely agree I
just think structurally that's a flaw
for both movies as the same Remy fan
that I just can't help right now then
love it more than than what kind of
forever which I think was just a little
more uneven I think at least Multiverse
Madness was a it was an even Sam Raimi
movie throughout
um when it comes to uh no way home I
mean what can we say about this film
that is amazing and I think ultimately
uh a lot of the critics in no way home
believe like well how could this not be
a great movie you're just cashed in on
Nostalgia points I think this movie
deserves more credit for how well John
Watts made us care with a grounded
Narrative of an anxious teen desperately
going after what he wants and what does
he want he wants to help his friends get
into college by becoming a nobody which
what a noble goal to want anonymity uh
trying to have it all he does all the
right stuff but he gets punished for it
he pays the biggest prices for it he
goes to Dark Places he breaks our hearts
with a tragic sacrifice in the Final Act
my favorite parts of this movie were in
the coffee shops you know the just the
teen drama of opening your college
acceptance letters at the same time we
get introduced to a freaking Daredevil
in this movie what a win uh and you know
this Toby and Andrew Garfield [ __ ]
didn't have to work this could have been
hard Toby McGuire not a good guy in real
life but we love him in this movie like
the fact that they're able to like fix
things that we didn't like about the
Toby era and Andrew Garfield era and
like make those retroactively look like
brilliant things that were inevitable uh
with their destination points in this
movie I think this movie was better than
endgame I think this movie is definitely
better than endgame Willem Dafoe I think
gives the best performance of the face
no shame on Angela Bassett she
definitely deserves an oscar but like
Willem definitely think was incredible
in this movie and uh and this was not a
guaranteed win I think this is a very
difficult win to pull off and the fact
that they did was great Jess I hear your
complaints though I think Jamie Foxx's a
lecture was really underdeveloped didn't
need to be in a movie I think the movie
probably spends a bit too long in the
opening act dealing with Peter's legal
troubles but you know hey at least it
Clips along real fast and the jokes are
great I to me this is a top five MCU
movie and I don't think the other movies
on our is our top five MCU overall
that's so funny I would never put that
movie Above end game but
I'm genuinely like oh Toby Maguire again
I guess I just was Spider-Man I want
something new that is like all I want
and maybe that's just my quarrel is like
with why Spider-Man and Multiverse
Madness are my four and three we'll just
go to mine Asian Americans have the
hardest time getting anything and
especially roles yeah and we have a
movie that put them in Jordans on the
back of a dragon to like and the
choreography everything the family
relationship the fact that we all called
The Mandarin the Mandarin for years and
it wasn't until this movie where we
addressed that it was offensive is like
remarkable to me the fact that a movie
actually like we can watch other things
and be like yeah this is offensive yeah
it's bad it's bad but we even watching
Iron Man still referred to him as the
Mandarin and that movie is not old so
I'm just like the fact that they were
able to address that to make you be
proud of who you are and who like your
name and don't let anyone change it is
remarkable to me and and the fact like
I've been begging for stuff like this
for three whole phases and then they
finally give us diversity in the fourth
phase we reach so many different like we
broke so many walls like ceilings like
we did so much in phase four that we
never did in the other phases and those
weren't old those weren't long ago I
don't know why we didn't reach it
earlier and even like acknowledging that
we only still have shung Chi like we
don't have Cindy Moon we don't have
anyone else so I'm like I are we like uh
we have some eternals we have Gemma Chan
that's great but I'm like I want more
and I want more diversity and shanxi is
a beautiful film and I think they did a
great job at Family Dynamic and I if
they came out with a second one right
now I would be in that theater I saw
shenshi three times in theaters I was so
happy to see it and I want more and
that's coming from a little a little
black girl from Olympia Washington but
no there's is no there's no question
about the hard work Ryan coogler had to
change things flip flop it take it throw
it and slam dunk it for wakanda forever
the fact that like so many hiccups came
in their way and he was still able to
create something so heavy and so
beautiful that I couldn't get up out of
my seat at the end of the movie and I
have not felt that way about any movie
in phase four there was not a single
movie that ended and I sat in my seat
and someone said Jessica the movie's
over you have to go
and I
I love it I I mean rooting for everybody
black uh I I I love I love diversity and
I took until the phase four and I will
always stand on that soapbox of I need
it and these two movies are new to me
um even if black panther had a first
movie it's still new to me and it's not
the same characters I've been seeing for
the last three faces a child you like
literally will kind of forever like had
so many powerful black women in it like
we've never really seen a superhero
movie with powerful black women like
this before
um like we had Riri we had um Okoye we
had again the the home girl from the the
other girl from the other midnight
sister but I keep forgetting your name
Michael Kayla Cole Michaela Cole the
actress
um and we had Queen Ramona with an
incredible performance and like it's
just like it's about time you know and I
really want to see more like like you
said like phase four was huge for
diversity like massive like including
the uh the Disney Plus shows because we
got Miss Marvel we got um She-Hulk we
got like we just had so so much
especially for women like this phase was
so great for women and I'm so much I'm
looking forward to like that secret Wars
moment where we get another like like an
a force moment like we we sort of got
teased in that game but like we got a
legitimate sequence I want to see a huge
fight oh all the women that we got
that'd be so freaking dope god um but
anyways yeah
so good
um but I guess we should talk about my
two now I guess
um but yes no I guess it's going on
wakanda forever which was my number two
um so like that movie
like I just love anything black panther
like before black panther even appeared
in Civil War I have been like the
biggest Black Panther fan like I've been
trying to I was preaching to everybody
like the channel is amazing and like and
like it really broke my heart when
Chadwick Boseman passed away and I was
I'm really wondering how they're gonna
handle that and like to actually put
like the real world element of a
sickness and add that to the story and
like not shy away from what the reality
of the situation was but do it with like
such tact and like also just make it a
part of like such a powerful story
between two Nations
um and like also I really loved how they
they put Chadwick's
um oh sorry well this you know Chadwick
is a great guy as well but like they put
t'challa's
um merciful nature in the Forefront
especially at the very end of the movie
with um you know
um shuri
like it's basically saying what t'challa
said to Zemo it's like vengeance is
ruining us all let's you know hold hands
together and uh let's be friends even
though you killed my mom which couldn't
be me could not be me I'm sorry uh
Sherry's a better person than I am
because like not me yeah every day
you're being able we we scrapping but
yeah no I thought that was really cool
and like it's sort of honored t'challa's
Legacy in the MCU in a very special way
and again a bunch of awesome black women
can't go wrong with that
um but Spider-Man no way home I think
was
it was tough for me to to because I was
thinking about what kind of forever
being my number one but like Spider-Man
no way home was just a really solid
experience just in terms of
um just exploring
the the Spider-Man like with great power
um becomes a great responsibility having
that be the Crux of the film and like
and especially with the film being a
very clear
um uh metaphor on immigration and like
you know it's it's essentially like a
response to what was happening in the
world at the time
um when um it was being written and with
um the the the villains of Noe home
being immigrants to this universe and
like they're like hey we should send
them back no we should we should help
them out and like I really loved how
they made a Spider-Man movie like a like
a Spider-Man movie like a huge movie
have it at actual meaning
um to real life and um I I thought that
they handled it spectacularly
um and um seeing Toby o'guire and Andrew
having Andrew Garfield get that like you
are amazing moment was like super
special to me and very and like I
haven't been happening in catch MJ those
two moments just like wow Marvel Studios
is the great Redeemer because like they
really know how to like sit bring
characters back that didn't really get
their best shot
um with you know so like Sony's Amazing
Spider-Man movies not exactly the best
and Kevin feige was like all right
here's everyone everyone loves every
Andrew Garfield again and like everyone
is gonna claim that they love The
Amazing Spider-Man 2 even though you're
lying you're lie even though I I love
being a big Spiderman too but like no
one was pre-loving that movie until no
way home let's be real uh people that
love Emma Stone did because it's true
Emma Stone
she is Gwen Stacy um but no Spider-Man
no way home was a really like a
celebration of Spider-Man and I I think
that um John Watts knocked it out of the
park he had like an impossible task I do
not envy that man
um but he he pulled it off and he he
gave us like a Marvel experience that is
like truly an end game level experience
it's like holy [ __ ] no one really
thought that this would ever happen we
never thought that we'd see Toby suit up
again if we got it which is like in the
MCU MCU Cannon so number one but me I
think both of you make a good a lot of
good points especially you Jess uh I
mean obviously we disagreed uh on these
things but like I don't want uh anyone
to feel like I'm taking anything away
from what kind of forever or shun Chi
because both were very beautiful films
and like we needed these films way
earlier you know I think fans needed
these films in these films had such a
difficult task ultimately and that they
were both miracles in in certain ways
the fact that they were as good and as
well liked as they were and were able to
reach out and connect with people in
ways that like my two top two films
definitely didn't you know I'm I'm
definitely grounded in like MCU World
building and nerdery and and script
structure and I probably care way more
about different structures do that's
what makes our difference better that's
what makes the difference is better I
would hate that if we all have the same
freaking opinion right yeah
be so boring and also only one of us is
wrong and it's Mt choosing black widows
number six
it will never be over that I thought I I
thought we were friends yo
yo yo once I saw freaking guy real son
with this freaking show up with that
really terrible his name is
like come on like taika I love you bro
you make amazing movies but this is
unacceptable the thing is the thing is I
just my thing about it is you put it at
six which means there's something below
it and that's impossible that's the
impossible part for me it's what I'm
saying four four oh my God I'm gonna
shoot very much to support you anyway
sorry it's fine but these are all great
times these are not terrible these are
not Electro level films what I loved
about hearing each of your lists is it
told me I I think I already knew a lot
about the two of you but like both of
you opened my eyes with the way with how
you ranked your priorities and it made
me love you even more in the way you
look at these films and it told me more
about like how what you appreciate why
you appreciate it and I want to thank
both of you I mean today's the day of
thankfulness I'm thankful for the two of
you for being able to pray uh so clearly
illustrate what you love about these
films in ways that opened my eyes so
thank you I'm begging for you Eric too
your list was great too there's nothing
wrong with your list at all everyone's
list was great even your list at home
your list is the right list can't wait
to see all the videos what we were wrong
one
well yeah let us know in the comments
below what you loved about each of our
lists but only what you loved about each
of our lists this is Thanksgiving this
is a good holiday fight with your
parents
we'll leave it there for this episode of
inside Marvel I think in future weeks we
need to talk about uh Wayne the MCU
Disney plus titles uh phase four against
the theatrical films like I kind of feel
like there's an interesting conversation
there but uh either way follow Jessica
and Lulu underscore Clements follow Mt
at masterton follow me at eava subscribe
to inside Marvel wherever you get your
podcasts thank you so much for watching
again Happy Thanksgiving uh eat some pie
enjoy your time and have a great weekend
everyone bye-bye wakanda forever
sponsored by Kamala Harris